hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from 1918.
this was a casual game played in new
york between the great capablanca on the
white end
and mark foneroff mark foneroff
was a professor at the new york
institute of musical art
today i believe it's known as the
manhattan school of music
and it was there he taught the violin
from 1903
until his retirement in 1927.
this game is regarded by many as a
brilliancy one of cappa blanca's
prettiest games and it certainly has an
elegant finish so let's dive in and
check out this
22 mover kappa opening with the king
pawn
mark fonoroff likes that idea as well
we have a scotch opening denoted by move
3 d4
some early pressure with this opening on
e5
uh black on this move 3
says i don't want to give up my e5 pawn
i'm going to try and hang on to it lend
some support there
that is not considered best considered
best is to
take on d4 a couple differences between
this capture and the move played in the
game
is that with this capture on d4 the
bishop's eyes stay opened
and black retains the option to play d5
in just one move to later challenge
white's fourth rank pawn
okay in this game it's d6 and so white's
d-pawn lives
at least for the moment and has the
option
to now advance grab space establish
itself in black's house and do so with
an attack
white can play this move it is certainly
an option
if white is going to play d5 it is
probably best to play d5 right now
at a moment when in other words the c
pawn is
not obstructed those of you familiar
with this fixed central structure and
how they are staggered
will know that the c pawn will one day
be excited
to get to the c5 square that would be a
desirable pawn break for white
so to play d5-1 move later
so for example the first knight c3
and only then d5 how would the c
pawn get rolling conveniently
okay in this game cappa
has no interest in closing the center
instead he's going to try and overtake
black's e5 pawn let's see how he tries
to do this
first direct pressure and now
indirect pressure over e5
he's trying to kill a defender of this
point the knight's currently pinned
unpinned can white win upon
at this stage not quite still need some
development
kappa castles on this move six
why is white not winning with this
variation
well it's because after knight takes e5
there would follow bishop takes e4 and
we're simply exchanging
e pawns so more
development is necessary castles rook e1
now things are a little bit different if
we revisit
this variation the e pawn is reinforced
this is now a threat to chop on c6
and chop away on e5
black understood this captures on d4
releases the tension in the center gives
up
his strong fourth ranked pawn and it's
important that black
play in this way release the tension
let's see why i was actually very
surprised
at how lengthy uh the variation can turn
out to be
before we can observe with clarity
white winning some material
so for example if black castles here we
go
chop chop queen exchange
knight takes e we're not done yet
white has one upon but a student of the
game who's a little bit
curious a little bit more curious seeing
a bit deeper at this moment will
question
wait a second can i not still take the
pawn on e4
uh if you take the pawn on e4 you're
going to end up
losing even more material
let's see how chop chop chop
we cannot chop again we're going to get
mated
back rank mate the winning move for
white in this position
kicks off with knight d3 cutting the
rook off from seeing d1
and now there are two unprotected pieces
on the e
file and the white rook is hungry
what do you do you move the knight you
lose the bishop
you protect the knight the knight gets a
kick
he actually doesn't have to move though
there's this check
pretty lengthy huh if the king goes to
the corner there's knight f2
if the king goes to f1 the knight is
poison because black is in a position to
recapture with the discover check and
the knight is hit
wow well the winning continuation from
this point is to
chop away develop the bishop
and we got a lot of pieces on dark
squares we're hitting the rook
and we're ready to dive into e7 with a
fork
what do you do in anticipation of the
fork defending the knight
bishop e7 who's the defender of the
knight
we like to deflect defenders
only at this stage do we now see
white's going to win even more material
than just a pawn
okay pretty lengthy variation
but one that i found kind of interesting
after this rookie one move yeah
you gotta do something about that
central tension is the short story
black captures and now notice how the
white
pieces immediately make use
of this central square d4 now that the
e5 pawn is on the sidelines
the king knight makes use of that square
the queen
and soon we're going to have this queen
knight
pivot on d4
this is significant i mean currently if
we do a piece comparison the queens
white's queen is looking pretty good
not easily kicked from that square
those of you thinking about c5 are
probably not thinking enough about the
weak squares you create
on the d file d6 pawn would be half dead
d5 would be a huge hole king is still in
the center
not a good idea to play c5 okay
what does black play castles
only at this stage does black castle
is this pawn poison it is
if you chop on a7 now there would be c5
cutting the queen from defense you could
defend it
but now you're in a pickle you're in a
pin
okay most experienced players don't even
think twice
uh even think for a second about
grabbing that a7 pawn
he is poison we have queen c3
this move uh this next maneuver with the
queen reminded me
some of game six
of the 1972 world chess championship
match
fisher playing as white in that game
against spassky
in that game fisher's queen uh went from
the queen side that's where there was
some activity
and that and that side of the board and
then it slid
all the way over to the king side and
then that's where
uh something new started brewing
we have a similar thing going on here
this is a nice pivot
queen is on a completely opened
third rank and also
vacating d4 moreover there is now a
threat
on c7 the threat to take with the queen
not the knight because pin scenario
so we have this threat right here how
exactly should black
parry that threat one of the computer
moves is d5 i don't want to go down that
line it is interesting
white can actually win a pawn but black
enjoys some very nice activity
the two moves i'd like to investigate
here i'll throw a pop quiz your way
how would you reply to this threat
against c7
queen takes c7 would you play
a6 or would you play c6
which one do you think is better
and why i think that's the only
no i probably have a pop quiz towards
the end with the elegant combination but
yeah i guess this is pop quiz one of two
for this video feel free to pause the
video what would you play
a6 or c6 what's the difference
okay in the game we have
c6 the knight has to do something in
both cases
um i believe that
a6 would be better primary reason for
this thought is you do not weaken d6
note that this is a half open file and
if you're playing c6
d6 is a whole and white can apply
pressure to it
in many ways
um by playing a6 again this would be
poison to take with the knight
a6 would shoot the knight away and this
would remain solid
the d6 square black can look forward to
some repositioning putting the bishop on
f6
rook on e8 okay in this game it is
c6 and we are soon going to
witness the significance of c6
versus a6 d6
is now a huge focal point for capablanca
pivots on d4 with an i and f5
a killer square for a knight especially
so
when there are no light square bishops
around
it's much more difficult to address a
knight
a white knight on f5 when there isn't a
light square bishop around you could
control it with g6
that is not without its issues
f6 and h6 would be weakened
and we know who's still around that
could take advantage of those squares
there are a few pieces still around that
can take advantage of f6 and h6
okay knight d4
knight d7 knight f5
drifting towards the king side now
knight on f5
queen on g3 if you're gonna make a queen
move
if you want to improve as a player
here's a tip
try and find at least two good reasons
behind every move you make
especially when it's a queen move
she's a multi-purpose piece get her
doing more than just one thing
she's doing more than one thing right
here coordinating on d6
and reminding black that this bishop
can't go too far
otherwise there'll be a mate threat on
g7
now usually in this scenario where a
point
a pawn in this case is attacked twice
and defended zero
usually will drop not here
it's an exceptional case the knight can
actually block
the queen's direct sight of d6 and open
the queen's eyes to d6
so this is defended for the moment
but white still applies pressure to it
however indirect
there are three pieces keying in on d6
if only that guy's still back here and
black had played a6
okay queen c7 white now centralizes
black gets a rook involved as well
and here we go with
an initial sacrifice rook takes d6
is played this is not entirely sound
there is a way for black to reply and
have it be a level position
considered best at this moment is to
play
h4 kind of squeezing uh
extracting let's say the most out of
uh the h-pawn creating a flight square
and potentially looking to use that as a
battering ram
against black's kingside
the move played in the game rook takes
d6
black replies with the recapture the
rook
and now we have bishop takes e5
uh what is this move doing well
something has to be done
over the d6 rook he's hit a ton
and what do you do what do you do about
that if you take the bishop
at this stage white will recapture with
the queen
there's a problem on d6 and there is no
longer
defense at this moment at least over g7
white has a mate threat and looking to
simply win the rook and be up at night
and upon the best at this point would be
f6
and white winds material there is a way
out
however on this move 18.
black can with this next move play
here we go queen to a5
hitting the rook unprotected rook on e1
threatening mate in one
and threatening the bishop
considered best from here is the
following line
bishop c3 bishop takes bishop
pawn takes and black currently up the
exchange we'll have to give it back
this is still a problem the mate threat
and the rook
best defense would be rook g6 and we
have this continuation
white gets the material back is
currently up a pawn but it does not feel
like
white is up upon uh with this
messed up queen side structure it is a
level position
black ready to scoop up a pawn and have
a passer
it's an even position okay
i'm fine that mark did not find queen to
a5 because we would not have seen this
elegant combination okay
no queen a5 here the move played rook to
d1 a very clever looking move by black
uh no time to take the queen no time to
take the bishop black's threatening me
white takes the rook and now black takes
on e5
currently black is down upon hitting the
queen
defending g7 and threatening b2 as well
maybe it appears at this stage black is
going to get
uh get the material back that is not so
so this is again just a 22 move
uh game what is this elegant
combination final pop quiz
pop quiz two of two white to move
let's see if you can spot cappa blanca's
elegant
finish okay
here we go it's beautiful
first knight h6
exploiting the pin only one move
and now move number two maybe the one
that was tricky to spot after knight h6
there is queen takes bishop
white is now up a piece and a pawn after
queen takes queen the move played in the
game
we now have knight f7 notice with this
capture on e5
white has pulled away at least one
defender of the back rank
with this combination white is
exploiting
black's back rank weakness
both sides had back rank weaknesses in
this game
neither had a flight square throughout
but white is the one who pounces
is able to pounce first knight takes f7
is the final move of this game black
resigns
if rook takes knight there's rook d8
and all you could do is block eventually
it's mate
and if you play king g8 the only other
move we take the queen
and enjoy being up a night and two pawns
which is too much so a very nice
finish to this one elegant finish
and i hope you
appreciate this uh
final combination a bit more
you know before we get to
this final combination yo what what are
the factors that led to it
these opening and middle game decisions
uh this idea by white early on to apply
pressure to the e5 pawn bringing it to a
point where
black felt compelled it was necessary
for black to give up the e5 point
and once it was given up notice how
both white knights and the white queen
made
use of that d4 square
white made very good use of d4
the knight made use of it the queen
eventually they shifted over to the king
side and let's not forget the difference
between a6 and c6
with c6 in that meant d6 was soft
it's weakened and kappa was
laser focused on applying pressure to
that weak point
on d6 and then and only then
do we get to appreciate in the endgame
phase
in this elegant combination
anyhow that's all for this video
as usual i hope you got something out of
it
and hope you're having a great day
that's all for now
take care bye